I've drink like a hundred iced
macchiatos a day and practically nothing
else there's a really cool coffee place
jitters at the Steamtown mall you've
been there no
you've never been to jitters Brian you
are so dorky give me your number second
text you have email dress I think
something a little fishy is going on
fishy
that little girl is a child I don't want
to see you sniffing around her anymore
this afternoon do you understand boy
have you lost your mind cause I'll help
you find what you're looking for
nobody gonna help you out there Jesus
can come through that door he's not
gonna help you if you don't stop
sniffing after my child okay Stanley
yelled at me today that was one of the
most frightening experiences of my life
I wake up every morning in the bed
that's too small driving my daughter to
a school that's too expensive and then I
go to work to a job for which I get paid
too little but on pretzel day well I
like pretzel day because they actually
got tough in everything what they were
asking about was cupcakes
The Chronicles of Narnia who invented
cupcakes right hey hey fellas what are
you doing I'm just saying hi to Bob no I
think you're cutting in line
those little bills got no money shuttle
down no way Oh get in the back please
[Music]
the pair of Mary's this is pretzel day
there you are I don't think we have
finished with my Inbox
what Scott's taught has a really mention
years local businessman legends college
tuition to third graders yes I have a
dream and it's not some MLK dream for
equality I want to own a decommissioned
lighthouse and I want to live at the top
and nobody knows I live there and
there's a button that I can press and
launch that lighthouse into space any
suggestions
yes Andy what if we changed her outgoing
answering machine message so it just had
a little more zing and a little more
pepper cayenne pepper see that's those
are the kind of words we're looking for
yes Jim what about if we did an even
newer voicemail message that had even
more zing and pepper now we're cooking I
like this maybe a whole theme like a rap
a rap rhyme herb in the name an urban
yeah San Li you want to help us out with
that
Stanley eartha Stanley none me yes come
on Stanley put your little game down and
join the group no Stanley we're alone
down having a brainstorm session did I
stutter
good this is good I'm going to grab a
glass of water
hey Jim
Stanley's back from the hospital today
can you sign us car great glad they
didn't mix up your tonsillectomy with a
mustache acta me oh that's not good
well because your jokes are all
hilarious it's nice it's funny it
mentions his tonsillectomy and makes a
funny little joke about his mustache
Stanley doesn't have a mustache yeah he
does Pam hit the brakes
Stanley does not have a moustache I
misspoke I not sure I think he has one
now that I think it has a mustache okay
Phyllis sits across from him every day
Phyllis does he have a mustache or not
oh I don't know now I think he doesn't
Phyllis what are you talking the whole
car depends on this okay the man has
worked here for 25 years how can none of
us picture his face because we come here
to do our jobs we don't stick our noses
in other people's business okay which
one of these looks more right neither of
those looks like any person that has
ever existed or been dreamt of in the
history of human insanity that said the
one on the left guys
that's the elevator what if it's him
okay quick
who says mustache yep who says no
mustache
welcome back Stanley Stanley you crush
your wife during sex in your heart sucks
bull mosted Oscar you are you're gay Wow
Andy Cornell call they think you suck
and you're gayer than Oscar all right
then I bet I was right just seems kind
of crazy in a way I might need right now
I don't know oh that's not yours
Stanley just drank OJ out of my mug and
didn't seem to realize that it wasn't
his hot coffee so the question has to be
asked is there no limit to what he won't
notice what's a seven-letter word from
purse actual No starts with an H handbag
hmm thank you
all right everybody take a seat as you
may have heard our branch on the planet
Jupiter is up eight thousand percent in
sales pluck a slope it is five o'clock
see you all tomorrow
hi Stanley love you so long Stanley
everybody do they bring in food do you
get to go out and bring it in you lucky
son of a [__]
I have been trying to get on jury duty
every single year since I was 18 years
old to get to go sit in an
air-conditioned room downtown judging
people or my lunch is paid 400 what is
this him a meatball really it's always
more fun to mess with the white with an
audience that was usually Pam so now
that she's out I had to find someone
else turns out that Stanley is quite the
comedy fan but not everything makes him
laugh he has very specific tastes
through a painstaking process of trial
and error I found out what he likes and
it's really weird Jim come on so
juvenile
what up you've been meatball are you
ready for some meatball this is not very
clever Jim really Jim really very funny
okay good
what's a hole 32 meatballs good day
that idiots been feeding us for a week
we'll never have to buy meatballs again
very simple there are only three rules
you must not touch the ground you must
not step outside of the ring and you
must always wear the safety mittens we
don't have an easy mitt probably left
them in the trunk of my car it's alright
it's alright here we go get a big boy
[Music]
sorry about that it's all about taking
points away from the white yeah no good
okay oh my god
I've never seen that look in a man's
eyes ever I thought that I might die on
beach day
you